today I want to talk to you about the
difference between being a leader and a
leaner
I'm Patrick may dividend today I want to
talk to you about one of the most
frustrating things and leading an
organization if your leader yourself
you'll know exactly what I'm talking
about you know in in anywhere you look
at in any business you'll always get to
different kinds of people leaders and
leaders and have you ever met somebody
before where you meet with them for the
first time and you walk away saying this
person is so impressive I am so
impressed with this person they are so
amazing they they can do so well they
can do such great things and then you
ask yourself the real question but how
come to heaven for they've been in a
workforce for 10 years 20 years 30 years
are they just a good talker or they just
good at selling themselves but what is
it well you know leadership is something
that very few people actually see the
work of a leader a leader is not
necessarily the stuff you see on you
know out there when everybody's
recognizing them they're getting a
trophy leadership is really what you do
behind the scenes and a lot of times
behind-the-scenes leaders who know the
difference between leaders and leaners
okay there's a lot of people majority of
any organization you're in majority
damar leaners and a few the people in
organization are leaders and a lot of
times these leaders inspire are the
leaners to eventually become leaders
every leader was once a leaner leading
on a leader leaning on a leader to learn
so they can duplicate it but I'll say
every time I hire somebody and I bring
somebody and I give him a leadership
position to company anything I've done
over the years when I hire somebody and
I put them in a position where they're
leaning I tell them I said listen you
are the CEO of this department I'm
expecting you to lead this department
I'm expecting you to perform in this
department
I believe you can pull it off but I want
to see you win in this department you're
to see other departments I want you to
lead I don't want you to lean on
everybody all the time waiting for
orders to be given I want you to use
your creative thoughts to create things
in this department that's what I want to
see with you and a lot of times what
happens to people is they'll look at
this and they'll say well I'm a leader
because I'm in the 20% I'll remember
this so this is a tricky thing I'm gonna
tell you the 80/20 rule you know how
this 80% and then 20% are leaders well
once you become the 20% a lot of people
who are in the 20% of that 100% they
stay in that 20
but a leader of that 20% says well wait
a minute mid-80s nth or my the 20% of
that 20% then that 20% of people there
is a 20% of that 20% then when they lead
to the next level even in that small
group there are people that lean on
others because everybody's a leader then
that 20% says I might the 20% of that
20% over 80% I know it's kind of
confusing but our leaders striving
constantly to move up and to me the 20%
to be the 1% to move up to be the small
or leader that's taking on more
responsibilities from the top to mover
more leadership positions from the top
so eventually gets to the top and the
person above them says you know what you
can do better job than I am you take
over my position because you've been
leading for such a long time I'm proud
of you this position is now yours but
it'll only happen to those that have
made a decision and committed to leading
not constantly leaning there is a big
difference when you look at your
organization and your people you think
about when you mark him down it's very
good exercise to write and say the sky's
a leaner
he seems like a lead everybody thinks
he's a leader but he's truly a leaner he
is still leaning when is this guy gonna
start leading my challenge to you is in
every single category of 80/20 you get
to you be the leader of the 20% not the
leaner and the 80%
it's my message of the week to him
please be sure to subscribe to this
channel and comment on the bottom